hola buenas tardes pues hemos visto como
la convención republicana ha querido
marcar la diferencia frente a lo que
vimos la semana pasada por parte de la
convención demócrata será mitad virtual
y mitad presencial inicio con
transmisiones virtuales desde muy
temprano y a diferencia de lo
acostumbrado tradicionalmente en la
política estadounidense donde se nómina
al candidato del partido a la
presidencia y vicepresidencia durante la
mitad de la convención y luego ciudad de
la aceptación al final el presidente de
una nación decidió que se diera esta
votación así lo hicieron los delegados y
fueron confirmados tanto tram como pence
para hacer los candidatos oficiales de
la reelección a la presidencia y la
vicepresidencia de los estados unidos
así que hoy vimos este proceso de walk
on y de llamado a votación por parte de
los delegados también el presidente dio
la sorpresa apareció en el auditorio
aunque se espera que su discurso final
de aceptación y de plataforma de lo que
será
su presidencia en 2021 si llega a ser
reelegido cede el jueves desde la casa
blanca hoy el tema central de la
convención será la tierra de las
promesas y también veremos a varios
representantes no solo del partido
republicano sino también de la familia
del presidente dando discursos al igual
que vídeos de ciudadanos en los eeuu
hablando sobre lo que han sido las
políticas del presidente de donald trump
y como los han beneficiado a ellos